oh wait we're not supposed to tell each
other oh the other side I back to the
top side so you want all the options I
thought they would be able to see this
[Music]
pick a rapper turned actor to play your
sidekick like if he was gonna be in a
movie so the options are 50 cent ice-t
Donald Glover jobs can be you know Ice
Cube Mark Wahlberg or common who you
want
I say Ice Cube you say Ice Cube why you
say Ice Cube I say ice cube cuz he's
stone faces don't like I think he's a
perfect straight man perfect I like that
I like childish gambino love like donald
glover
i like the range that he could cover and
i feel like in a scene we could go back
and forth from playing the straight man
to go from drama to comedy he all the
time other i just like his range okay
pick a spot to put your new tattoo on
your knuckles your neck your face your
chest yeah your pinky toe yeah or your
butt my chops it depends on what the
tattoo is though like where it would go
right right are you putting no tattoo on
my neck because you can always put Jay
to the left
that is that that would be hot that's
right oh I wish I think my ass oh it's a
to build my hair I think I ask what it
would be I would just want to use all
the parts as part of the tattoo yeah
where'd you go with your tattoo knuckles
all right now pick an action-movie star
to play the villain Oh Sammy onto
Sylvester Stallone Jackie Chan interest
Elba Keanu Reeves the Wayne Johnson I
had to go with Sam L Jack go Sam Jackson
just cousin Sam Sam bad boy oh man you
know what I think Keanu is about due to
play a bad guy I think like he's been
he's been growing in his life he's been
experiencing a lot of things that that I
think there's a well he could tap into
that could be really really freaking
scary you pick a project from bad boys 3
cast member to watch ooh okay Riverdale
Riverdale night before Christmas night
before Christmas
Vikings celebrate music video yeah High
School Musical games Alexander in
Vikings is crazy
Alexander in Vikings gonna have real
skills look at Alexander look
yeah and he's so not that I'd like to
see Charles in Riverdale jostle yeah
finally pick an iconic action to act in
hmm leaving a building seconds before it
explodes we've done that already
high-speed car chase a shootout against
you and poor other people yeah we did
that jumping between buildings an
unrealistic distance yeah no mom did dad
broke his ankle right he broke his ankle
step in to save your partner at the
exact moment the villain thinks they've
won I like that I like that's a good one
dodged several bullets that definitely
should have hit you I like that I like I
think I would do that yeah uh I would
say go forth no no no no no no I got you
by the neck bullet catch a bullet
[Music]
25% bad boy what the higher that's funny
no no best buddy you're a sweetie pie
and that's a great characteristic to
have instead of intimidating others you
make them feel comfortable
50% bad boy what it means you're the
perfect balance of a good and bad boy
you know when the bring the bit the heat
and went to change the flame yeah that
sounds like it so so so that means
together we 75% back
that's right that's right
[Music]